first of all you have been you and
Joanne were such a big part of my life
growing up body break was just always a
staple in my house so I want to know
from you you put up this video the
reaction has been so strong were you
surprised to get this kind of reaction
and and how does that feel for you well
I knew it was an important video in
terms of all the videos that we released
so I wanted to do it right but we're
just shocked and overwhelmed and humbled
that it has done so well and so many
people who responded in such a positive
way Joanne was reading a lot of the
comments on YouTube and she started to
tear up she started to get emotional
because people were so opening up to us
about their experiences and what body
break meant to them as a minority see a
mixed-race couple and seeing somebody of
color constantly on television it made
them feel good so it made it made us
feel good we kind of then start
reflecting back into you know 1988 and
you know 32 years ago that we we started
all this journey so it's been it's been
a great ride no regrets and certainly no
bitterness that over the years at all
about things
well that's didn't want to talk about
with you you are so positive even in
your video you're extremely positive
when you're talking about things that
were just not fair how do you stay
positive and what advice do you have for
other people who are frustrated right
now
well you know a lot of things a lot of
things in life are not fair but you got
to plow through it you just go okay
there's always a way you can get around
it there's always a way you can make
something happen I laugh because there's
many successes that we've had through
through business and through we've had a
hundred failures and so I I expect that
I expect to fail because I'll find
another way around it so I don't get
frustrated or mad you certainly can't
get mad because when you get mad you
can't think straight
you can't think what are your options so
that's why I just you know you take it
down you get knocked down you get up you
figure out how
you can do it yeah when you posted your
video how we battled racism he spoke
about how it wasn't originally started
as a fitness purpose that it was
actually to combat racism so can you
explain a little bit more about that
well it's uh you know I had I had some
roadblocks as far as racism is concerned
I was hired and fired at TSN and one day
and and I didn't even do anything it was
fact that the higher-ups didn't want to
have two black reporters on at the same
time they the country was ready for that
so those are the things that spurt one
of the things that spurred me on to
think okay how can we do this how can we
show that we can all live work and play
together and so one of the ways is and I
thought well if you give people medicine
a little bit at a time that they don't
even know they're taking it and you mix
it up with with a nice concoction
they'll drink it and not even realize
they're getting better and so that's
what we did with body break we showed
Joanna and I interracial couple we
showed that it wasn't by accident by the
people that were behind us whether it be
Asian whether it be persons with
disabilities whether it be black people
people of color different ethnicities
were always in our show so we would go
to a casting agency we'd say we need we
need this this this we need to I I need
a hearing-impaired asian woman to be in
a particular spot those we went
specifically to show certain things
because what that person who's who's
let's say who's hearing impaired that
person will will see themselves on TV
you may not see that somebody's doing
sign language in the background but
they'll see themselves and they'll bring
a smile to their face and they will
they'll feel good about themselves and
feel good about our show so we want to
be inclusive so that everyone sees
themselves on the show on our show and
and we've been we did over 300 episodes
a body break that I just love that's
amazing that's so amazing and it's
affected so many people I mean anybody
even this morning I was like yes so I'm
interviewing like it's just you know
body break had such a strong impact on
so many people I mean when you posted
this video TSN
released an apology how did you react to
that well at first I was they didn't
need to I wasn't I was kind of surprised
I'm not a victim I hold no bitterness
the interesting thing is TSN was the the
number one station that played us in
Canada they played us more than any
other station across Canada and I was on
The Amazing Race which is a CTV and I
was on off-the-record over a hundred
episodes I have absolutely no ill will
towards TSN and I've been in that
building over a hundred times and so it
was just something that one person they
were I I was looking at they weren't
prejudiced they weren't racist they were
afraid they were afraid to make a
decision out of the norm and what the
great thing is today people aren't
afraid they and they they're being
pushed to make those what they call
tough decisions so his fear was he
didn't want to lose his job if he does
something wrong and he thinks what's out
of normal and so normal is is that's
what we've tried to make body break as
normal to society that you see everybody
that we can all live work and play
together so you do think that it is
possible to see more change in this
industry oh absolutely I mean it what's
what's equally as important is in front
of the camera is behind the camera and
that's what I think is so important and
that the people in the in the the
c-suites making those decisions on what
stories to cover what you know what
angles to cover the stories those are
the things that are important as well as
people in front of the camera I've been
in literally hundreds of meetings
advertising marketing meetings doing
different projects different things that
we've run we've got a body but fitness
equipment for example where we could
have packages boxes now we own the
company Joanna so we are the ones that
making the decision
so one company brought me a agency get
brought me the packaging and there was
different people little icons on those
and all those people were awake and
said to them I said is this a joke I
said we want a person with a disability
we want a a senior and we want people of
color on this because that's who Canada
is and they were they were kind of oh
but these were all people all they were
all white people who weren't thinking
like that and now you know this is you
know 10 12 years ago I remember having
that meeting but because Joe and I are
sensitive that and we're the
decision-makers we can make a decision
and so he said send it back we want we
want the proper thing on there you know
I think some people and I've heard
people say this that's racism is way
worse in in the US and you know it's so
much better here in Canada what do you
say to people who say that well I say
that I mean it is I've lived in the
States for 10 years I went to the
University of Colorado I lived in
Washington DC Long Beach San Francisco
Denver Boulder
so it's I've lived all throughout the
United States and so the United States
when I go there now we just drove down I
don't drive at night through certain
places like Oklahoma Illinois Indiana
those places at night because were
stopped by police because I don't want
to be out there at night
the Krays were stopped by police it's a
lot it's a I feel hunted when I'm in the
u.s. I feel much more relaxed so so as a
person living here I feel it's and
having both experiences it is far better
in Canada than in the u.s. there is
systemic racism that people are not even
aware of I think in Canada or Canadians
aren't aware of but I think over the
past three weeks I've gotten so many
phone calls from my friends both white
and black but my white friends were
talking we're having a discussion and
they were there saying I never knew I
never realized and what they're saying
is they don't know what to say they know
they're afraid to put something out on
social media supporting one thing or
supporting another thing because they're
going to be
you know you're you know you're gonna be
a race called a racist or late to the
party or whatever it might be so they're
afraid and I think what I look at is
saying it is it's everyone is just
listen listen and and talk to one
another about it and if you do we can
all kind of grow from that and and and
because you don't solve anything from
yelling if I yell at you I'm not
thinking straight and and you're
shutting your ears off and not listening
so what's accomplished yeah no
absolutely and it's really cuz I do I
have friends who are a little scared
some not all friends but some people
they're just not sure what they should
do and how they should navigate this
yeah yeah but they want to help and they
want to if they want to help with the
change yeah I have a friend of mine
actually Julie
Lola Julie from The Amazing Race that
are good friends he's uh the blind racer
they've become very good friends with
Joanna and I I was talking to Julie
after the video was out and she said do
I have a cause she wants to donate money
to a good black lives matter type of
cause do I have one that I would
recommend for her to donate money to and
I said well not in particular but you
know what you're doing is just go talk
to people go go don't ask questions of
how do you feel hot and and then that's
really important as well just to have a
conversation and don't be afraid yeah
you know there are so many things that
really stood out to me in your video and
one of them was just one of the
incidents where they wanted to move you
from away from a white woman because
they were concerned that people wouldn't
be okay with an interracial couple so is
that something that you've you and
Joanna had to deal with over the years
well we we had to deal with it but not I
say not really we just ignore it things
is that when you know we those those
people if they don't affect you in your
in your work or your life kind of thing
just in northern they're not worth your
time they're not worth your energy
because you don't and they're not worth
get over so that's kind of what I kind
of my attitude towards things is is
don't waste your time on people that
that don't deserve your time so but when
I I whatever I went through as you're
growing up my mom and dad an interracial
couple see that to me is normal I
thought I thought every kid's parents
were black and white that was as I grew
up as a kid and I said oh you only got
two white parents I have one of each you
know kind of thing but what my parents
went through was so much more difficult
than than what I were Joe an have gone
through it's just you know it was
illegal in certain states in the US and
that's where they they lived when I was
born for them to be married so it's it's
it's a very very different time and my
dad who's 88 said to me that this is the
most hopeful time he's he's ever seen me
so he's more hopeful now than ever
before which is which is fantastic oh I
love to hear that okay so so is there a
message that you want to leave with
everyone with everything that's going on
in the world right now yeah I just
understand we're in a period of change I
understand we're all emotional there's
an emotion we don't even know where this
is coming from it's a cove it is it you
know seeing someone actually executed in
front of us there's so many emotions
that we're having that they're you know
kind of juggling in beside us and so
understanding touch those emotions and
then go out and and talk to somebody
talk to even like your white friends now
one of the things that I was taught by
my mom is that she said when somebody
says something about another race not
your race but makes a joke about another
race I predominately Jewish area is that
so I had all these Jewish friends
growing up so when I would hear somebody
say something about about a Jewish
person I would be thinking about my
friend Joel or lesser Mike all of my
Jewish friends and so that person wasn't
saying it against a race they were
saying against my friend
so I was I would then defending my
friend so when you hear somebody say
something
about another race speak up tell them
it's wrong right off the bat